it is true it is a fact that Jews lived
and flourished in the Muslim and Arab
lands and anybody who would like to see
for themselves go to uh uh Tunisia
Morocco um Iran Egypt and um and Yemen
and all the lands there and prior to any
human rights groups to protect uh prior
you can go you can find the synagogues
uh that were there till recent uh recent
times and some of them still exist in
Iran they still they are there people
are practicing the religion there the
Jewish religion uh but um till recently
till Zionism came about Jews flourished
as as distinctly religious Jewish
communities and they weren't massacred
on the contrary they went to these Arab
and Muslim lands to escape persecution
uh from the Crusades from the
Inquisition and from many other trials
and tribulations and the um and even
World War II uh the Arab and Muslim
lands opened their hearts opened their
lands and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious Hospitality for the Jewish
people again clearly they we we have
different religion um and yet uh we were
we were accepted in these Muslim and
arbl we believe in one God and we were
accepted we have different ways of
serving God and but yet as I we were
respected and even the Muslim religion
requires of that of the uh the Muslim
people to to Pro provide protection and
hospitality and they did uh carry that
out that's clear nobody could refute
this fact um although unfortunately
Zionism and the Zionist uh zionists try
constantly to vilify the Muslim people
and try to recreate uh uh a a scenario
of as if we have some deep embedded
religious conflict and and hate between
Jews and Muslims and that is
so deplorable despicable and really it's
there's no words it's a nakba and let me
try to explain really people have to
understand you know I through in word
Zionism and this what what we talking
about here yeah what is it most people
are ignorant now when you hear Zionism
you know what's the difference between
Judaism and Zionism yeah uh with God's
help the
Judaism is a religion it's it is a
covenant that Jewish people made some
3,000 years ago on Mount Si uh to be
subservient to God and to follow the
laws of the Torah 6133 Commandments in
the Torah we in the Torah is full of
laws that are rep some um a large
segment of them have to do with keeping
Sabbath kosher things that pertain from
um us as human beings to the almighty
and then there is a large segment of the
Torah that pertains to that one should
not steal and one not kill and to be
compassionate and so forth um it's all
there's are many many Commandments it's
all part and parcel of the Torah in fact
uh we can ACC Compass it this one of the
commands one of the statements is that
um that Ma in Hebrew it says
Mah just as God is compassionate you
should be compassionate so basically
that is what Judaism is Zionism is a
mere 100 odd years it was a movement of
Jews who were estranged to the Torah who
detest the Torah and tried to transform
this Judaism into whereat Judaism a new
Judaism which is pure nationalism
material concept of having an army
Olympic team and to be a nation proud
amongst other nations totally removing
in its Essence uh the concept of
godliness removing God from U from the
equation and they will allow religion
they say or how far they do or don't but
they are have hijacked the name Israel
they've hijacked the whole uh um uh
Judaism to legitimize and to put a
facade of that it's kosher that it's uh
Godly what they're doing when in truth
it contradicts Judaism and it's totally
forbidden and I'll explain why with God
can you before we go to break so can you
be a a can you be Jewish and an atheist
of course not it's ridiculous that the
Judaism is belief in God that's what
it's all about a covenant with God it's
not a nationalism it's not some type of
a country that you can be a Democrat you
can be a a Marxist or something while
Zionism exactly is exactly that they
were marxists and they claimed to be
Democrats and they proudly claim that
they're that they you don't have to be a
PR practicing Jew and and and to be a
good Jew as long as he supporting the
state so that of itself shows the heresy
and the blasphemy and what this is but
there's much more to what we're talking
the issue of Zionism and I would really
have to elaborate a little bit on what
this is uh on on what Zionism how in
every facet it Rebels against God and it
um it it is uh uh it it is rooted in
heresy in in in nonbelief in God and in
doing evil basically basically uh before
we go to break just one more thing it
really touched a lot of the hearts when
people have heard you say that Jews and
Muslims at one point when they were
living before this this whole
nationalistic atheistic movement Zionism
is it safe to say that's what it is an
atheistic nationalistic movement
certainly so now before that uh they
were actually babysitting each other's
kids so if you're leaving a kid with
someone your own you know Flesh and
Blood your your your joy of your heart
you know this is not your en precious
the most precious of possession that a
person has it's what God gave a person
and Jews and Muslims will leave their
kids they live in the same Courtyards we
have many Jews who are alive today to to
thank God and they lived in the old
Courtyards and in Old Jerusalem to
testify and they could testify this and
uh to this uh uh both from the Arab
Muslim people and the Jewish communities
I have many colleagues of that we're
going to take a break and we're going to
talk about a lot more here in